Michel ça s'est passé il y a 50 ans
c'est une histoire qui était tombée dans
l'oubli malheureusement alors
rappelez-nous un peu le fil des
événements oui c'est peut-être une des
pires tragédies de la médecine
contemporaine alors c'est un produit qui
a été vendu dans 46 pays sous 68 marques
de commercial différentes et c'est une
compagnie allemande en fait qui a vendu
ce produitlà pour en fait toutes ces
choses-là de l'irritabilité à
l'éjaculation précoce passant par le
trac l'anxiété la tuberculose et même la
grip j'en passe alors quand on a on a
rajouté un an plus tard une autre
application c'était la nausée pour les
femmes enceinte alors il a fallu
attendre un an ou deux avant de
commencer à vooir les malformations chez
les enfants si on regarde ça en 61
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest et le Royaume-Uni
mettent un terme à ça le Canada lui est
un peu lent quelques mois plus tard au
total 12000 victimes dans 46 pays et 125
au Canada il en reste 95 de vivants et
comment expliquer qu'il pu y avoir un
tel dérapage bon sur le plan
scientifique on a utilisé des rongeurs
et malheureusement on n vu aucun effet
maintenant on ne fait plus ça on utilise
plusieurs animaux pour mesurer les
effets pour ce qui est de l'utilisation
chez les femmes enceintes la compagnie
dit qu'elle a eu la vie d'un médecin le
médecin est ni donc c'est une pratique
dans l'ensemble qui est très mauvaise
depuis on a eu beaucoup de changements
la Talidomide a fait modifier entre
autres la loi américaine qui dit que on
ne peut plus maintenant regarder juste
l'efficacité de médicament il faut voir
son innocuité et on a également eu un
centre mondial de pharmacovigilance donc
ça a un impact positif mais espérons
Céline que ça ne se reproduise plus
jamais ouais ça a été un dur réveil pour
les agences réglementaires oui
absolument merci beaucoup Michel merci
Céline